grew up watching this guy Al Harrington
is here what's up baby hey man good to
see you bro thanks for having me dogs uh
the Cannabis uh I would like to I was
just telling you off off camera but
you're like one of the OG guys who
really got into the weed game and like
did it the right way all right you just
celebrated 10 years uh two years almost
two years ago now that's crazy yeah bro
so I mean
we've seen a lot of celebrities come and
go in the weed space right like I was
just thinking about this the other day
like me and my boy were talking about
like Jay-Z's weed we're like what
happened to that right like what
happened to Jay-Z's weed like it was an
announcement it was this big deal and
then it just went away right you know
what I mean but like I feel like you've
done such a great job of just like
diving in obviously being a smoker
um coming from the background you come
from like for you like how does it feel
to kind of
look back you have a has your weed
career almost matched your MBA career
Years bro almost I'm at I'm at 12 in the
week game and I play 16. wow so uh I'm
getting close but I think the first
thing is like I never considered my
brand a celebrity brand right you know
what I'm saying no that's what's crazy
is you kind of had to do a little diving
in to be like oh Al Harrington's behind
yeah it was never LED that was never the
intention right right the attention was
always about my grandmother and really
about just you know the benefits and
changing the stigma around kids Viola
your grandma's name okay okay so that
makes sense okay yeah yeah yeah so the
story goes pretty much I had uh she had
come to see me play uh she was you know
taking all this medication back so why
she gave me a list of things one of the
things she said was glaucoma I told her
about an article I was reading literally
two days before she got there about how
cannabis cure glaucoma patients she
asked me what was Cannabis I said
marijuana week she's laughed so hard she
was like rifa you trying to get me to
smoke
and I was like well Grandma they said
doctors she like no the next day she
come I come home from shoot around and
she's complaining saying how she can't
see so I said look just try this to be
our secret I won't tell nobody this
would be me and you just you and me you
don't say I have my boy go to dispensary
bought some Vietnam cushions the strain
that we bought back
um had her try it so I took her
downstairs where were you playing at at
the time I was playing in Denver okay
let's get going you know what I'm saying
so took it downstairs I went took my nap
hour and a half later I had smoked weed
at one time in my life and it was in
Phoenix okay and I was so paranoid that
night I was like I'll Never Smoke Weed
again dead ass so like [__] we I don't
know why y'all smoke this [__] type
thing so I said make sure she's not
going down and you know going she's not
dealing with the same thing so I go
downstairs knock on the door I don't
hear nothing so I'm like well she must
be knocked out so I knock again and I
just open the door but when I open the
door she's sitting at the edge of the
bed and her back to the door she's
looking down so I said Grandma how you
feeling and she literally she turns
around and she's crying too she says I'm
Healed she said you know I haven't been
able to read the words in my Bible in
over three and a half years wow so I was
like what she was like every everything
is so bright like God gave me my sight
back so that's what inspired me to learn
about cannabis amazing and pretty much
you know eight months later I made my
first investment I bought a building in
Colorado and I started growing as a
caregiver so all the patients that I had
either had like HIV or cancer and
whatever was left over that we didn't
give to them we sold to dispensaries wow
and that's how I got started you know
what I'm saying so it's always been
about it's amazing but it's always been
about her it's always been about the
power of the plant for me you know what
I'm saying not you know I still to this
day haven't put anything with my image
on it my name on it for sure for sure
yeah it's all been about the plant you
know yeah it's it's crazy I did so what
are the benefits of like someone has HIV
of cannabis because it helps with like
pain okay appetite you know what I'm
saying because they deal with a lot of
efforts yeah for sure absolutely
advertise one of the biggest things you
know what I'm saying yo it's crazy tell
me okay so you get high in Phoenix
because that's where I'm from you guys
played the Suns that night so this is
the reason this is the reason why I got
high bro so I'm playing for Golden State
okay so the year before we had just we
were the We Believe team yeah we had
knocked off Dallas right so the next
year we come back better we think we
really think we're gonna win a
championship that year right so things
that happen during our throughout That
season like we had an opportunity to
trade for Kevin Garnett right and they
did not [__] make who were they gonna
trade for Katie the kid uh Brandon
[__] the kid that we drafted from
North Carolina they wanted like a draft
pick they wouldn't like young players
right right so it was always going to
trade all these players for him they
reneg on the trade we end up wait the
Warriors said no the Warriors said no
bro Jesus so we end up bringing in Chris
Webber okay so Chris Webber comes in but
you know at this point Chris was a shell
of himself big shout out to the OG
injury the injuries really cooked him at
the end bro he ends up playing like 12
games for us right and out of those 12
games we end up winning like four out of
four out of the 12 games so come down to
the end of the season we need to win all
the games to make the playoffs right so
we last game of the season
um we all we had to do was beat Phoenix
we knew he was going to be Phoenix
because we had Monte Ellis who used to
he asked about 40 but he averaged 40 on
Steve Nash it was literally like give
him the ball and let him bust Steve Nash
yeah Steve was not the greatest defense
like literally that's how we beat them
yeah every game that year just gave
Montana
so we knew we were going to win you know
what I'm saying but we needed the
Clippers to beat Denver oh so you you
even if you won you didn't control your
destiny right we just need but we
there's the night before though we still
we just so the night before the game we
need Denver excuse me we need the
Clippers to beat Denver and this isn't
good Clippers this is not good Clippers
yeah so obviously they lose so now our
season's over even if we win the game it
doesn't matter right so everybody's
frustrated you know we think we're gonna
build off of last year and you know
Baron wheel you know we got a good team
you know what I'm saying and everybody
they just start smoking so they like so
I'm sitting in I'm having a drink they
like bro you gotta Smoke Dog yeah like
come on the season over bro it's over
like smoke yeah so I smoke or whatever
and uh like I said like 30 45 minutes
later bro I'm like okay nobody I'm gonna
go to my room yeah
and I went in the room bro I was felt
like the road was closing in on me I
felt like I was hearing Sirens I was
just bugging you know what I'm saying I
can't even go out that night like we go
we know we go out there yeah I even go
out I was like I'm done I just so that
was my first experience smoking weed you
know what I'm saying so I was like I'm
cool and obviously you know that was
weed from the bay so you know it was
something some real real it was some you
know I'm saying not for somebody's first
time for sure you know what I'm saying
so it just melted your face off and
turned you off I was finished so are you
do you smoke now I smoke every day oh
good I'm high right now shout out to you
hell yeah bro